There're several ways of how we can deal with visuospatial knowledge.
In fact in your projects you've already come across some of them. So imagine
there is a figure here. Here is a triangle with the apex facing to the right.
Here is another triangle with the apex facing to the left. So in one view,
the AI agent can extract propositional representations out of figures like this.
And similarly propositional representations out of figures like this. So
this is a propositional representation, this is a propositional representation.
And then, the AI agent can work on these propositional representations to
produce new propositional representations. So some AI agent can
use a logic engine or a production rule to say that this particular triangle,
which was rotated 90 degrees, has not been rotated to 270 degrees. So
although the input wasn't in formula's figures, the action here was at the level
of propositional representations of these figures. The agent may extract
propositional representations like this through image processing, through image
segmentation, perhaps using some techniques like constraint propagation as well.
Alternatively, the agent may have analogical representations.
In these analogical representations,
it is a structural correspondence between the representation and
the external figure. So the external world headed triangle like this, and
the analogical representation will also have a triangle like this. Notice that
I'm using the term Analogical Representation, we use a separate thing from
analogical reasoning. We are not talking about analogical reasoning right now.
We're talking about analogical representation and analogical representation is
one, which is some structural correspondence with the external world that is
being represented. Give a certain analogical representation, then I might want
affine transformations or set transformations to get this. So I may say that I
got this triangle out of that one, simply by the operation of reflection or
rotation. So these proposed representations in the previous view are A model.
They are separated from, divorced from the perceptual modality.
These analogical representations on the other hand,
are modal representations. They're very close to the perceptual modality.
And human cognition, mental imagery, appears to use analogical representations.
What would be an equally intuitive of computational imagery?
Human cognition is very good at using both propositional representations and
analogical representations. Computers however, are not yet
good at using analogical representations. Most computers, most of the time,
use only prepositional presentations. The same kind of analysis may apply to
other perceptual modalities, not just to our visual images. So here are two
measures and we can either extract proposed representations out of them and
then analyze those propositional representations. Or, we could think directly
with the relationship in these two particular measures. There is a question for
building queries of human cognition. When you're driving a car, and
you listen to a melody on your radio and you're reminded of something.
Reminded of a similar melody that you had heard earlier.
What exactly is happening? Are you extracting a purpose for
your presentation out of the melody that you just heard? And then
the proposition representation reminds you of the proposition representation for
a previously heard melody. Or, does a new melody somehow directly remind
you of a previously heard melody without any intermediate propositional
representation? These are our open issues in cognitive science,
as well as in knowledge based AI. In cognitive science, it is by now,
significant agreement that human cognition does use mental imagery at least
with visual images. But we don't know how to do mental imagery in computers.